you initially were really really excited
about this one into it how did that work
out for you it was this tunnel they just
get colder I kept saying the word
traumatic and I think it goes hand in
hand with what happened we googled
potential benefits and these are some of
the random completely unproven side
effects the internet told us could
happen if we took cold showers I just
want to take cold showers and suddenly
fix my life if that can happen we got an
agreement so I haven't done the research
but I'm assuming it's gonna do things to
me so the first couple of days were
terrible my heart just started beating
[Music]
but by about day five I think my body
just started getting accustomed to the
cold water shower number five was
significantly easier I mean the initial
blast is going to be terrible but it's
like jumping into a cold pool just got
to jump right in your body will adjust
to the temperature I'm gonna actually
say I'm kind of starting to enjoy it I
started learning the less I thought
about taking a cold shower the easier it
was to take it shower number six felt
great cold shower number eight felt
great I never thought I'd be a cold
shower person but I really love this I
really never got used to it they tell
you you get never you can never get used
to this
it's just not possible anyone who says
they got used to it 100%
they're lying I was really shocked
because about halfway through this
I was voluntarily taking cold showers I
thought myself excited to take cold
showers I'm looking forward to it I just
got back from a night out with my
friends and I'm kind of drunk I really
want a cold shower to kind of sober me
up a little bit but I never thought I'd
be like voluntarily taking a cold shower
but I want to cold showers are great for
hangovers at that shower oulous yeah
incendiary so cold showers definitely
gave me a lot more energy on the days
when I was hungover or on the rainy days
when I was lethargic energized part
believe it it's like adrenaline going
through and incredible amounts just like
right now I'm feeling very very
energized like again like I have many
cups of coffee you feel energized
ass-fuck and by that I mean like like B
smells like Hulk whatever you call that
creature is gonna come out of you and
you better watch out cold shower 19 well
great I am ready to dominate the day by
the time I was out I was energized as
rejuvenated and ready to take on the
Dame so you get exciting you like oh my
god this cold showers I'll take this but
the half an hour later go back to your
usual self and you can drag it like what
is going on here just bag to be lazy I'm
here I'm sorry my skin is looking
it really is one of the things I know it
is was definitely the skin my skin all
over it feels great face arms everything
looks amazing my skin has been
incredible and my hair has never felt
smoother typically I have terrible bags
under my eyes that don't go away and
those have been better my energy my mood
everything has been a lot better I think
that there was an evolution in the hair
so after complaining about my hair
looking dry and unhealthy hair looks
super dry oh my god I thought it was
gonna do marvelous things to my hair
that is finally changing my hair is
looking better healthier shinier it's
looking pretty good do it my husband was
like oh my god he looks shiny it looks
like you have healthy normal hair for
the very first time and I was like oh my
god that is freaking true it looks like
like that actually
stylized it but truth is I barely
brushed it the volume is beautiful this
shine it looks so strong I would say one
of the biggest benefits of taking a cold
shower was that I was significantly less
sweaty than I normally am oh my god yeah
typically by this point I would have
slowly started to sweat through my
entire shirt even in an air-conditioned
subway but no sweat the sweat marks on
the shirt I think I can vibe with the
cold shower I think I get it now day 30
the last day the cold shower challenge I
never thought I would have made it this
far with this much acceptance I've seen
so many health benefits from this I'm
not sweaty my skin's better my hair
better my mood is better ready and a
little sad to take my last cold showers
yeah it will be pretty cool to know that
taking a hot shower it's okay if you can
commit to taking a cold shower in the
morning which is something that's not
enjoyable and then you can almost reach
kind of this meditative place where
you're trying not to think about the
cold water and you're trying just to
enjoy it and you're trying to push those
negative feelings and negative thoughts
out then that really kind of just
overlaps into your day sort of like
these cathartic experience but do I feel
that philosophical today Oh [ __ ]
that's something I really loved about
the cold showers it's just the willpower
in the commitment it took did I enjoy it
like genuinely enjoyed it no absolutely
not I think this is something I'm gonna
adopt [ __ ] oh [ __ ]